chez ans la collectivité européenne
d'alsace ne verra le jour que dans deux
ans mais les présidents des deux
conseils départementaux val d'avancer
sur les sujets clés et notamment la
coopération transfrontalière
ce matin ils ont précisé les futurs
chantiers à mettre en oeuvre à savoir
bilinguisme emploi et transport stéphane
baudry eric klein offert collectivités
européennes le nom veut tout dire
l'alsace veut se tourner vers
l'allemagne et la suisse plus que vers
la lorraine et la champagne et cela
passe d'abord par la langue l'allemand
en perte de vitesse en alsace malgré le
million d'euros investis chaque année
dans chaque département depuis 30 ans
alors la collectivité unique veut
innover recruter directement les
enseignants ajouter des heures
d'allemand à l'emploi du temps des
élèves rendre l'apprentissage plus
ludique et soutenir les échanges
scolaires de proximité de part et
d'autre du rhin des actions pour
lesquelles il va falloir de nouvelles
compétences que les présidents des deux
départements volts aller chercher à
matignon par les expérimentations par
ledroit différenciation qui qui qui est
aujourd'hui est envisagée on peut
montrer à capacité à agir si l'alsace
était par exemple premier est le terreau
de l'expérimentation des fonds européens
et ensuite ça s'est déployé beaucoup
plus largement ben je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a cette légitimité à
agir travers la collectivité européenne
d'alsace qui nous est reconnue mais tous
les jours il faudra compter pour aller
encore un petit peu plus loin des
compétences a précisé aux matières
d'enseignement mais aussi de santé et
d'économie ou de transport avec la
renaissance des lignes sarrebruck alunno
karlsruhe et colmar fribourg et on la
matière le chantier de la préfet se
nomme se présente comme un laboratoire
nous avons déjà démarré et beaucoup de
choses et nous allons les développer
par exemple dans le domaine de la
professional mme nous sommes en train de
construire une zone franco allemande sur
le territoire de fessenheim dans le
domaine des mobilités aussi on nous
travaillons d'arrache-pied avec les
allemands pour remettre en service une
liaison ferroviaire entre colmar et
fribourg les deux départements ont
désormais deux ans pour avancer avec
suisses et allemands sur de nombreux
dossiers et négocier dans ce cadre leurs
futures prérogatives la collectivité
européenne entrera officiellement en
fonction le 1er janvier 2
21 et cette région à ja je alsace
justement qui y vit combien